oh wow  wow i seen a man  stand up for his wife  which we don't see that much anymore  that made me have hope they put her face  up on the screen he looked over at his  wife she was hurt i would like the more  of a straight apology  to chris you know  that would have been that would have  been great because i mean i thought  will's performance was amazing and i'm  sorry that he tarnished it with this  behavior nobody likes to be made fun of  but you got to have a sense of humor  ouch  man  crazy i'ma stay right out of it but  if i had to speak for my woman you know  i don't know everyone handles their  thing their own way you have to protect  your family and uh you know i believe in  him and what he stands for and so you  know he's a stand-up guy and i'll stick  by him